[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Kim PhD here this
is the iPhone 11 pro and this is the
iPhone fun fact I've never actually
owned a first generation iPhone or a
second gen or a 3rd gen the first iPhone
I ever owned and reviewed was the iPhone
5s this video it's mainly for fun but
it's also for people who make a habit of
complaining that this year's phones are
just last year's phones plus a few small
bumps because if you haven't noticed
that's kind of the whole point the whole
reason they're coming out with phones
over and over again year after year
besides trying to make as much money as
possible
is to offer a small bump and a small
improvement in year-over-year and then
when you do feel like upgrading it adds
up to a larger difference the three or
four years after you've finally decided
to upgrade these smartphones it's a
mature market it's very rare that we get
a truly revolutionary new device a
revolutionary new smartphone but back in
2007 this was that so I wanted to take a
quick look back at a retro phone that I
never used the original the iPhone so
first thing I'm noticing holding it now
in 2019 is its a chunky one you know
like this is a really thick phone but
it's also really small it honestly feels
about half the size of its much much
much younger brother and you know
generally it's the right shape the
rectangle with rounded corners with a
flat display these big chrome chamfers
big forehead big chin we know that and a
physical home button is there and it's
kind of rare these days but every corner
of this device is actually legitimately
reachable that's no problem at all and
the iconic two-tone metal and plastic
it's super recognizable as this first
iPhone you could probably tell as soon
as you saw the thumbnail this is of
course a used iPhone but it's held up
pretty well for a decade plus in
people's hands fun fact though we all
know most modern smartphones or maybe we
don't know but they're hiding their
antenna back
in the metal frame of the phone and
various places you can see it around the
phone this first iPhone didn't do that
it just put them all down in the bottom
half of the phone and made the bottom
plastic so that the radios and antennas
could go through that passes through
plastic better than metal simple as that
and then there's the display so while
today we have all these huge
high-resolution displays six to six and
a half inches for a display isn't even
blinked at anymore back here in 2007
we're looking at a 3.5 inch 320 by 480
LCD display can you see individual
pixels yes yes you can see individual
pixels it measures in at officially 163
PPI but it does get surprisingly bright
so I'm not even mad at that as soon as
you look at it a little bit off axis
though or you know even turn it off you
can see the huge difference versus the
laminated super high-tech high refresh
rate OLED panels we have today and
that's not even getting into the whole
folding phone thing but it's easy to
forget the display when this phone first
came out was I think the most
revolutionary part of the hardware the
fact that it was a glass display and it
had ten finger multi-touch and that was
a big leap for the mobile UI and I
remember when this one came out it was
on 18 T or singular only and I was a
high school kid on Verizon so I couldn't
just switch carriers to get it so I had
my first smartphone was an iPhone
competitor called the LG Voyager and I
don't know if you remember that but it
was also a touchscreen but it was a
resistive touchscreen and it wasn't
multi-touch and it was just a very very
different experience
not all touchscreens are created alike
so this was a big deal I did still enjoy
the Voyager though I did review it good
times
this is obviously a touchscreen phone on
the front and a multimedia texting
device on the inside the bottom of the
original iPhone is maybe where it shows
us age the most that is the og 30 pin
connector and the speaker and microphone
down here in those grills which means
about the top is where you'll find the
headphone jack
but not just any headphone jack
you can see closely here this is a
recessed three-and-a-half millimeter
headphone jack so if you had headphones
with the right diameter then you were
fine but if you had a thicker cable or
if you had a certain right angle
connector they wouldn't work and you'd
have to get an extender basically a
headphone jack two headphone jack dongle
power button is up at the top volume
rocker on the left it stayed this way
for a while until they move the power
button to the right for the first time
in the iPhone 6 and then that's next to
Loki one of the most significant Apple
designs I think in their mobile history
because something they've stuck with for
every single iPhone to this day and
that's the dedicated mute switch let me
let me read to you the spec sheet of the
original iPhone from 2007 now keep in
mind when this came out it was not about
specs that's not what people were
impressed with about the iPhone but it
had specs so this is just for reference
for how far we've come it had a Samsung
made CPU under clocked to 412 megahertz
and you can see on the back it was an 8
gigabyte version but you could get 4 or
later 8 or 16 gigs of storage and all
versions had 128 megabytes of RAM and
then you're looking at a hefty 1,400
milliamp hour battery oh and that's a 2
megapixel camera on the back no multiple
lenses no flash no microphones just a
simple camera no bump and opening up
that camera app you can see just how
simple it all started it's literally
just a viewfinder and a shutter button
like that's all you needed there's no
tap to focus no tap to expose there's no
portrait mode no Knight mode no video
mode at all and no selfie mode either oh
yeah that's right the first iPhone
didn't have a selfie camera in fact no
iPhones had selfie cameras until the
iPhone 4 so as your trivia fun fact of
the day and here's some photos I've
taken on the iPhone 1 and you know on
one hand I'm actually pretty impressed
that they still look decent at all I
mean I wouldn't post these but you know
at least the colors are decent but on
the other hand you can tell it's
basically a webcam you know there's
noise in every photo
no matter how much light you give it and
it's like splotchy noise exposure is
impossible to nail focus is impossible
to nail yeah it's bad but that's what
makes it so incredible is that
comparison with the iPhone we have today
and the fact that this was one of the
major stepping stones to the mobile
photography that we kind of take for
granted in our pockets this is the best
Apple could make 12 years ago versus the
best Apple could make today which has me
really pumped about the best we're gonna
have another decade from now and then
performance well it would be almost
unfair to review the performance now but
it's actually pretty impressive that it
still turns on boots up and works the
battery life is about three hours since
it's a decade-old small battery but for
the most part you can see the software
like it existed back in the day the last
software update the original iPhone got
from you know literally the first
version of iOS was iOS 3.1.3 that you
can see here and you can see how simple
it is there's just slide to unlock no
touch ID no face ID it's fairly
responsive but you know no control
center no notification shade all these
things came later in fact believe it or
not the first version of iOS didn't even
have wallpapers that was eventually
added as a feature plus some nifty
default wallpapers were added that have
slowly become iconic I also look at this
voice memo app I can actually see how
this is one of those things that really
excited people in 2007 it's impressively
smooth anyway I don't know about you but
seeing the two of these phones
side-by-side really sort of refreshes my
appreciation for how good this mobile
tech has gotten especially lately if you
go back to the internet wayback machine
archive you can see what Apple's website
looked like on that fateful day in 2007
when this thing launched and they called
it a breakthrough communications device
and all that fun stuff my favorite part
is if you click through to the high-tech
section they talk about the crazy new
sensors that they put in this phone
including an accelerometer so it can
tell when you're holding it portrait or
landscape and rotate automatically and
an ambient light sensor so it can raise
or lower the brightness thereby
enhancing the user experience and saving
power at the same time and then of
course this thing spawned
odd touch first piece of tech I ever
bought and the iPad and all the iPhones
that came after it and the rest is
history
this thing in arguably changed tech
design forever so anyway I hope you
enjoyed this fun little look back I
think this one will be amazing to do
like a sort of a challenge like I don't
know who else would do this maybe
another youtuber but like trying to use
just this phone for a week or something
I don't know who would do that maybe tag
someone if you have some ideas but yeah
it's just sort of fun to actually turn
it on use it and get some experience
with iOS 3.1.3 also this is a perfect
opportunity to give a little shout out
or a shameless plug to retro tech which
is coming back so a lot of you may
remember earlier this year we did a
pilot episode diving deep into the
original Gameboy I'll leave a link below
so now since then and I've tweeted this
we finished shooting and editing six
incredible episodes all of different
iconic pieces of retro tech and so
they're coming right at the beginning of
December and I am really excited for you
guys to see them I mean we spent a lot
of time on them but there's also some
amazing guests great segments they
turned out great so either way thanks
for watching this one and feel free to
leave a comment what was your first
smartphone if mine was the LG Voyager
was yours the iPhone or was yours
something else
feel free to let me know I'll hang out
in the comments and I'll catch you guys
in the next one peace